hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde vor einigen tagen habe
ich hier ein video auf meinem kanal
hochgeladen in dem ich jude und ich
kürbisse geschnitzt haben und unter dem
video wurde mensch viel diskutiert über
halloween und ob leute feiern und mit
welchem kostüm und ob sie losgehen oder
nicht und blabla und deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht ich zeige euch heute
einerseits einige der besten halloween
kostüme die ich online gefunden habe
allerdings auf der anderen seite auf
einige der beschäftigten halloween
kostüm als ich würde sagen wir fangen an
mit diesem kostüm die uns war das ein ja
ihr seht spaß es ist die schöne und das
biest fand ich ziemlich süß wie das
kleine mädchen als die schöne gegangen
ist und dann der hund bzw der website
verkleidet wurde als das biest
allerdings kommen wir jetzt auch schon
zu einem eher beschissene begrüßt du
hast halloween auf jeden fall gewonnen
das hier ist das nächste sehr
eindrucksvolle halloween kostüm und zwar
es ist ein kleines mädchen verkleidet
als schlange sandra wird komplett
durchdrehen denn die hass schlangen über
alles auf der anderen seite habe ich
allerdings auch wieder ein schlechtes
halloween-kostüm rausgesucht sonst war
ja ich weiß nicht ob es stimmt was dann
runter stand aber die person hat sich
als vogel kacke verkleidet und hat sich
deswegen vogel kacke ins gesicht
geschmiert
du hast auch halloween gewonnen das hier
ist das nächste kostüm das ich
ausgesucht habe und zwar es ist ein
kleines kind verkleidet als waschbär mit
einer waffe ich glaube dass der
tatsächlich aus irgendeinem film stammt
aus dem disney-film oder irgendwie sowas
ja auch mal im kino lief allerdings
machen wir es auch schon weiter mit dem
nächsten beschissenen halloween kostüm
das ist ein typ der sich irgendwie als
tomate angemalt hat haye muss man jetzt
nicht unbedingt checken allerdings ich
würde sagen machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten coolen halloween kostüm und
zwar sind das hier sohn und vater ihr
seht schon darunter stars im safe und
vater sms 11 an der halloween haben die
einfach rollen getauscht
also der vater ist als sohn gegangen und
er so dass als vater gegangen und dieses
bild bin ich ganz ehrlich das verwirrt
mein gehirn gerade ein bisschen mehr
allerdings nun wieder zum gegensatz zu
einem beschissenen halloween kostüm und
zwar wollte diese personen hier als
ironman gehen glaube ich ihr seht schon
wie beschissenes geworden ist und das
gesicht ist das allerbeste am ganzen
kostüm das nächste tolle halloween
kostüm hat sich aber auf jeden fall
rausgesucht habe ist das hier und zwar
sind das drei mädels die sich als nackte
sims unter der dusche verkleidet haben
und sogar dieses zensiert dings sich
ausgesucht haben auf pappe auf der
gegenseite als schlechtes halloween
kostüm habe ich allerdings an dass hier
für euch
ich glaube die personen die diesen
dekoartikel dahin gestellt
die weiß nicht wirklich was der sinn von
einem geist ist aber naja machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten tollen halloween
kostüme und zwar finde ich das einfach
sehr krass wie das als make up gemacht
wurde
ich habe allgemein kompletten respekt
davor wenn leute so übel krass mit
make-up und schminke umgehen können das
jetzt vielleicht bisschen komisch an
aber ich finde dass das hier wirklich
unfassbar krass gelungen ist die hat
sich als holzpuppe geschminkt und das am
ganzen körper
und dann kommen wir zum nächsten
halloween kostüm
ich zeige es euch einfach ohne ja ohne
irgendein kommentar weil ich glaube dass
braucht man hier tatsächlich nicht
allerdings kommen wir nun wieder in den
positiven bereich zu einem tollen
halloween kostüm wie ich finde zu einem
sehr kreativen halloween-kostümen wo ich
mich allerdings einfach nur frage wie
könnt ihr laufen
ich zeige es euch hier erstmal es sind
drei soldaten figuren und die stehen
halt wirklich auf dem blech drauf
deswegen ich habe keine ahnung wie die
sich von a nach b bewegen wollen vor
allem ihr allerdings nun direkt schon
wieder von der skyline zum bordstein und
schauen uns dieses kostüm an
ja ja ich glaube da muss ja auch nichts
mehr zu sagen das nächste halloween
kostüm ist allerdings wieder ein
ziemlich geiles halloween kostüm und
zwar hat das eine vater von einem
mädchen macht und dass mich ja das ganze
gepostet und meinte einfach nur so wie
viel arbeit hat mein vater bitten das
kostüm gesteckt ich meine schaut euch
einfach an
da steht nur eine person drin
und er trägt das ding nicht also er
trägt diesen diesem dieses gefängnis da
nicht sondern seine arme sind halt in
diesem käfig drin
das heißt es muss alles ohne bist du was
ich meine
ich finde es mega krass wenn sich leute
damit so unfassbar viel mühe geben
kommen allerdings nun zum beschissenen
halloween kostüm auf der anderen seite
und das ist tatsächlich eins wo sich
auch leute die mögen geben haben die
kinder feiern das allerdings nicht so
sind einfach babys die in pumpkins
sitzen und ihr seht schon kein babys so
wirklich gut gelaunt zum allerdings so
wieder zu einem kostüm wo sich die
person in dem kostüm wirklich auch
gefreut hat uns was ist passiert und ich
finde es mega süß das ist ein kleines
mädchen und der hund und ich glaube das
ist rumpelstilzchen oder bin ich blöd
waren wir jedoch direkt weiter mit einem
total bescheuerten halloween kostüm und
schwarz ist eine person die als
freiheitsstatue gehen wollte und die
person hatte irgendwie keine krone
deswegen hat er einfach drei meter
hinter sich plastikstühle so hingestellt
und jetzt sieht so aus als hätte er der
krone
allerdings muss man sagen wird es eine
menge kreativität die person die
allerdings auch eine menge kreativität
hat es die person die dieses halloween
kostüme gebastelt hat und zwar sind es
zwei riesige faultiere auf der anderen
seite habe ich allerdings dann das hier
also ich glaube die passt dass beide
mein kostüm nicht so richtig also ganz
kurz nur zur info ich habe die kostüme
übrigens nicht so sortiert von wegen hey
das ist bei den kostümen gut und das ist
bei den kostümen schlechte hinsichtlich
halloween sondern ich wollte es einfach
nur abwechselnd machen
tolles kostüm beschissenes kostüm und
weiter und so fort ich glaube ist auch
ein bisschen lustiger machen wir
allerdings nun direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten guten oder teuren halloween
kostüm und zweitens dass hier das ist
ein 1 pilot ich als pilot verkleidet
allerdings als blinder pilot und das ist
tatsächlich etwas was ich nie in dem
flieger sehen möchte dass der pilot zur
austritt das jetzt allerdings das
beschissene halloween kostüm und zwar
hat sich da einer als flash verleiten
wollen das kostüm war allerdings nicht
groß genug und hat er sich das sixpack
einfach mit einigen aufgemalt sehr gut
bürger das nächste tolle
halloween-kostüm finde ich allerdings
persönlich sehr sehr sehr sehr geil und
zwar was ist das hier
da sind zwei personen als portal
gegangen ich weiß ja wie porto gespielt
habt da geht es darum dass man zwei
verschiedene portale setzt also ein
oranges und ein blaues und dann kann man
quasi von dem blauen in das orangen
portal durchgehen und die haben seit so
gemacht als würde der eine gerade
dadurch gehen wollen
durch das blaue und kommt dann oben bei
dem orangen wieder raus finde ich also
auf jeden fall sehr sehr geil machen
allerdings geht weiter mit dem nächsten
beschäftigen halloween-kostümen stars
hier
da wollte sich alle personen als motzki
verkleiden ist schlussendlich nicht so
genau und gut geworden das nächste gute
halloween kostüm ist megageil meiner
ansicht nach und zwar hat sich jemand
als michael jackson verkleidet
allerdings nicht irgendwie als michael
jackson frühjahr wieder ganz damals
außer oder wir dann später in seiner
karriere außer sondern einfach beides in
einem
ich mein' hey wie krass ist es bitte und
dann gibt's auf der anderen seite
allerdings wieder eine person die ich
dachte hey ich gehe als kamel hat
allerdings die hinterbeine vergessen zum
kamel auf zwei beinen stark wirklich
stark wann allerdings direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten guten lu in kostümen was
ich sage mal gut ich meine bestimmt
haben sich auch einige der leute der
kostüme die hier gezeigt habe die
schlecht waren damit auch
höhe gegeben aber vielleicht konnten sie
einfach nicht so gut
so wie ich in der schule wer auch immer
mühe gegeben konnte es allerdings
trotzdem so gut hat sie jetzt auf jeden
fall das nächste tolle halloween-kostüm
dass ich draußen super und zwar ist das
von einer mutter die jedes jahr in extra
halloween-kostüm strikt für ihre tochter
und ich meinen wie krass sie das bitte
aus dann haben jedoch auch wieder ein
beschissenes halloween kostüm und zwar
das hier ja da wird glaube ich auch
einfach die falsche größe bestellt als
nächstes wieder ein tolles
halloween-kostüm uns war das zweite von
vier kostümen dass ich von dieser muster
ausgesucht habe die das halt für ihre
kinder strikt und zwar ist es das hier
das ist papa schlumpf und ich finde es
so süß
ich will dieses mädel sich auch freut
und ja dann haben wir als nächstes eine
person die als frozen gehen wollte
das ganze sei schlussendlich so aus dass
es einfach papier als haare und ein
eimer crashs im sinne von frozen und
dann gibt es wieder die mutter die für
ihr kind einen harry potter kostümen
gebastelt hat und sogar so einen kleinen
unsichtbaren draht mehr oder weniger von
dem zauberstab verbunden hat damit mit
der feder vorn und das ist auch jetzt
wenn die feder führt und dann meine
damen und herren haben wir wieder was
komplett beschissen und zwar wieder im
sinne von falsche größe bestellt
spongebob ja ich glaube das hätte ein
bisschen länger sein können hier vorne
allerdings habe ich nun doch schon zum
letzten respektablen halloween-kostüm
dass ich raus gesucht habe und zwar wie
bereits gesagt ist das wieder ein foto
von der mutter die für ihr kind ein
kostüm gebastelt hat und zwar ist es
wirklich das was ich auch am liebsten
hätte für halloween beziehungsweise für
karneval
ich meine in amerika ist ja eh so dass
man glaube ich an halloween sich jetzt
nicht unbedingt gruselig verkleidet
sondern da geht es allgemein um
verkleiden weil die halt karneval sowie
in köln beispielsweise nicht so richtig
haben es geht auf jeden fall bei dem
kostüm um pizza und das finde ich mega
süß und mégane eis auf der anderen seite
beenden wir das ganze dann allerdings
auch wieder mit einem beschissenen
halloween kostüm und zwar sind es zwei
geister in bikinis
ja super anderer stelle ich das heute
gewinnt jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde sehr viele von euch
haben wir unsere mein halloween kürbis
schnitzen video mit jude geschrieben nok
es gibt so viele geile kostüme aber
folgt beschrieben er luca reagiert auch
mal auf kostümfans von halloween
deswegen dachte ich bevor ich jetzt zwei
videos mache mache ich beides in einem
wenn es euch gefallen hat will ich mich
auf jeden fall sehr sehr toll war einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freude und schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare
ob jude und ich eventuell auch mal sowas
machen sollen mit halloween kostüm
sollen wir uns gegenseitig halloween
kostüm kaufen basteln für den anderen
wenn ihr da bock drauf hätte schreibt
gern und in die kommentare abonniert
main kanal weil es noch keinen trainer
luc schulzeit und managt abonnenten auf
die glocke dann verpasse keine videos
mehr und ich
muss glaube ich mal unsere kürbisse da
jetzt entsorgen weil die stadt anfang zu
schimmeln
[Musik]
zum 1